hier ging es auch in der pause sehr
lebendig weiter und wir machen es direkt
weiter mit tom larsen und seinem
intensiven schwindel ja vielen dank also
ich muss dazu sagen dass die gesamte
thematik nicht schon seit anfang der
korona krise beschäftigt und ich habe
mich gestern gefreut gestern sind
endlich alle daten angekommen viele
menschen da draußen werden
wahrscheinlich denken was daten sind ja
nicht aufregend ich finde das sehr
aufregend und ich habe seit gestern
vollständige krankenhausdaten 2009 10
und 20 und 21 und ich kann sagen es gibt
eigentlich eine gute nachricht und eine
schlechte die damit verbunden ist die
gute nachricht ist es gab nie eine
überlastung ist gesundheitssystems die
schlechte ist es gab eine unterlassung
des gesundheitssystems das heißt wir
haben in 2009 10 19,2 millionen menschen
in den krankenhäusern in deutschland
gehabt mit allen möglichen verschiedenen
diagnosen und krankheiten 2020 waren es
schon nur noch 16,7 2021 waren 16,6 dh
in deutschen krankenhäusern sind fünf
millionen menschen nicht in die
krankenhäuser gekommen ob sie jetzt
verschoben wurden aber mittlerweile nach
zwei jahren wird man sagen ich glaube
die leute wollen nicht mehr ins
krankenhaus und ich möchte die leute
animieren wenn sie leiden haben gehen
sie wieder ins krankenhaus das ist
glaube ich der richtige zeitpunkt denn
mittlerweile ist es so dass die dass die
menschen die in die intensivstation
kommen wo ich will das jetzt mal einfach
mal in einem zusammenhang setzen in den
intensivstationen wird natürlich auch
geld verdient das sind ja auch
wirtschaftsbetriebe die krankenhäuser
man darf das jetzt irgendwie nicht
übelnehmen auf der einen seite sind sie
für unsere gesundheit auf der anderen
seite verdienen sie geld aber wir sehen
eine zunahme auf den intensivstationen
gerade von pflege geraden und das ist
sehr brisant das müsste eigentlich auch
herr lauterbach untersuchen das ist ja
unser bundesgesundheitsminister bis
jetzt ist das nicht geschehen wir wissen
dass 20 aus 2020 zwei 100.000 menschen
zusätzlich auf deutsche
intensivstationen kann wo wir alle
gedacht haben die wären voll mit corona
patienten und es kam aber 100.000
zusätzliche pflege gerade und lignum
beispiel zu 59.000 alleine waren davon
80 plus also 80 und älter und in pflege
grad 3 4 und 5 die hat man zusätzlich in
2020 in die intensivstation verbracht
und was bedeutet das für die menschen
die menschen haben gedacht die sind voll
die intensivstation und was wird gemacht
es werden 50.000 zusätzliche menschen in
20 20 22 21 über 80 jahre war
eingeschoben die konsequenzen daraus die
möchte ich eigentlich gar nicht tiefer
beleuchten weil ich mir nur die zahlen
angesehen habe und ich hab gedacht das
ist eine katastrophe das ist in der tat
ein großes problem was wir seit jahren
haben auch bei der berichterstattung
über das gesundheitssystem das
gesundheitssystem ist ein riesengroßes
kosten jonglage system wohl der kunde
der patient ja nicht derjenige ist der
wie beim kauf eines fernsehers sagt ja
den habe ich gelesen stiftung war uns
jetzt sehr ist gut der kunde kann in der
regel gesundheitssystem nicht
einschätzen was der arzt ihm verordneten
wir haben über generationen von
gesundheitsministern immer das gleiche
problem gehabt das gesundheitssystem
weicht dahin aus wo es am meisten zu
verdienen gibt und das war im falle von
corona eben leider auch eine pauschale
bei der auslastung der intensivstationen
die wölfe bei 75 prozent lag und oh
wunder wenig später waren die
krankenhäuser alle bei etwa 75 prozent
da gab es nämlich diesen bonus obendrauf
und das ist genau das problem was dann
wiederum verzerrt den blick auf die
pandemie und auf die auslastung des
gesundheitssystems und das finde ich ist
hoch dringlich und muss politisch
aufgabe sie verkennen ja damit
eigentlich erstmal die lage das ist ja
nichts was ich dem gesundheitssystem
irgendwie an kreide sondern es sind ja
gerichtsentscheidung es sind leben
geschlossen worden ist denn existenzen
vernichtet worden mit der begründung die
überlastung des gesundheitssystems wäre
ein problem und jetzt sehe ich habe fünf
millionen weniger patienten wie kann ich
ein system mit fünf millionen weniger
patienten überlasst es geht gar nicht
das ist das motto ich ja noch auf die
intensivstation patienten von denen ich
jetzt erstmal sagen würde die waren im
vorjahr nicht da wohl die gleiche anzahl
da war dann ist das nicht überlassen
darum sage ich das muss politisch
aufgearbeitet werden denn die politik
aber dringt die politik weiß welche
anreize setzt und sie weiß auch dass
sich auf der basis dieser zahlen solche
lockdown maßnahmen nicht wirklich
begründen man sich einmal ganz kurz ein
haken zwar war es ja immer das wie immer
freie betten hatten es wurde auch
berichtet ich habe damals immer auf
twitter habe ich mal gepostet noch frei
war das war auch in der härtesten seit
12 wenn ich mich richtig jetzt in halo
mit daten sollte man immer vorsichtig
sein aber das eigentliche problem war
doch dass einzelne ortschaften einfach
sehr stark betroffen waren und das war
doch immer die angst das ist unser
gesundheitssystem zusammenbricht weil
halt ortsbezogen in manchen
krankenhäusern einheit wirklich in
erfüllung da war ja aber das ist ja
genau was ich vorhin schon sagen
394.000 menschen werden von deutschen
intensivstationen in 20 20 von einer
intensivstation in ein anderes
krankenhaus verlegt also wenn sie
194.000 verlegung haben also insgesamt
sind da 1,9 millionen patienten gewesen
ein prozent verlegen sie dann ist das
nicht ungewöhnlich dass solche patienten
verlegt das ist eine völlig normale
sache für die krankenhäuser das ist das
ist eingeübt eingespielt das sind jetzt
infektiöse patienten da sind natürlich
besondere dinge zu beachten aber ich
brauche dafür nicht die presse anrufen
und ich brauche schon gleich die
bundeswehr so also laut ihren daten gab
es keine überbelegung 1 ja ja wir
sollten nicht vergessen ich will dass
ich habe keinen zugang zu diesen zahlen
also sie wie sie die für das auch gar
nicht in frage stellen um aber die haben
sie das haben sie lange recherchiert und
das muss man ernst nehmen aber genau so
ernst muss man doch auch nehmen dass es
viele viele operationen da viele auch
die auf intensivstationen hätten kommen
sollen
für umwelt operationen durchzuführen
auch dringende operationen
krebspatienten oder was auch immer die
dieser bereits nicht durchführen konnten
weil diese intensivstationen belastet
waren oder belegt waren oder je nachdem
überbelegt waren mit corona patient und
dann frage ich mich auch das ist nicht
das muss ich drei morde und heute gerne
können sie in der recker und zweitens
können sie das dann auch klarstellen
weil das wirklich eine frage die ich
habe auch wieder nicht an meine
zionistische kollegen es gab immer die
berichte über die situation auf
intensivstationen pflegerinnen und
pfleger die gesagt wir sind hier am
anschlag es gab reportagen
die durch verschiedenen klinik flora
gegangen sind durch bedrückende sachen
wo auch sehr glaubhaft vermittelt worden
ist dass die pflegerinnen und pfleger
der wirklich ein höllenjob macht auch
aufgrund der überlastung ließ da gibt
da frage ich sie jetzt weil sie sagen
das gab es alles gar nicht also war das
alles ist eine fehlinformation die wir
erhalten haben also das gab es alles ich
fange mal hinten an das gab es alles gar
nicht habe ich natürlich nicht gesagt
sondern ich habe gesagt habe dass das
keine unterstützen es gibt tatsächlich
menschen die auf intensivstationen
arbeiten und dort sich belastet gewesen
belastet gefühlt haben das ist auch
nachvollziehbar weil die arbeit die auf
einer intensivstation sowieso
stattfindet ist immer mit tod und mit
krankheit verbunden das ist in der
intensivstation so ich kenne das selber
ich habe eine woche mal eine
intensivstation besucht aber als
besucher eines patienten also ich habe
meine schicht sozusagen mitgemacht und
kann das sagen wie das da abläuft das
sind tolle menschen auf den
intensivstationen das müssen die auch
dort sein wir haben eine zusatzbelastung
die müssen sich ein kittel müssten
teilweise schwitzen bestimmte arbeiten
machen das ist aber für die ganz normal
na ja da muss ich mal widersprechen wenn
man sich diese reportagen im anschaut
viele kollegen bei bild haben da auch
reportagen es gab eine sehr
eindrucksvolle
insbesondere im rbb wurde die glaub ich
dargestellt und da wenn man dort den
pflegern zuhört dann sagen sie das
corona intensivpatienten eben nicht wie
alle anderen patienten sind denn sie
müssen selbst in schutzanzügen arbeiten
was wahnsinnig anstrengend ist für
darauf legen was ich sagte ja genau und
gleichzeitig ist sozusagen ein crooner
intensiv patient wesentlich braucht noch
mehr arbeit als ich nenne man normale
intensivpatienten und der eindruck der
sich dort ergeben hat dass es zumindest
regional eine viel zu hohe belastung in
den intensivstationen für diese
pflegerinnen und pfleger gab ja und
gesagt wir können unsere arbeit
teilweise nicht mehr machen dafür ist ja
die verlegung da das ist ja das was
sozusagen auch gemacht wurde aber ich
musste natürlich zurück zu meinen daten
ich habe jetzt natürlich ein paar sachen
gesagt wo ich sagen okay ich war auch
nicht in jeder intensiv stadt so was ich
eigentlich sagen wollte ist auch der
professor marx vom nie wieder präsident
und auch die sämtlichen köpfe vom tv die
haben sich ja auch geäußert zur bundes
notbremse ist ja gesagt worden wir sind
überlastet und so weiter das problem
auch lauterbach hat sich übrigens dazu
geäußert der hat ja gesagt jetzt liegen
die 47 48 jährigen väter auf den sind
und die kinder verlieren ihre eltern
ich will denen das glauben das problem
ist nur die hohlen einzelne
jeden bekannte meinung ein ich besorge
mir daten von 1260 krankenhäusern von
1350 intensivstationen das heißt also
ich gucke da jetzt nicht mit
irgendwelchen emotionen drauf oder sonst
irgendwas sondern ich sehe einfach nur
die daten und wie dort gearbeitet wird
wie die auslastung prozentual war und so
weiter und ja natürlich ist sind es gibt
intensivstationen die fahren permanent
auf 100 prozent da ist immer feuer das
immer feuer und es gibt
intensivstationen die achten nicht
darauf die fahren noch mit 50 die müssen
auch hochfahren den intensivstationen
ist das vielleicht mal einmal ganz kurz
sagen eine intensivstation ist ja etwas
wo patienten in der schwersten notlage
sozusagen liegen müssen da brauchen sie
ganz viel apparate und die müssen
funktionieren und wenn sie sozusagen
schon zehn oder 20 betten haben und sie
haben da maschinen dann müssen sie auch
techniker in der nähe haben die müssen
auch bezahlt werden und sie haben da
nicht 124 oder 125 sondern sie haben
eins zu zwei patienten also ein pfleger
zwei patienten das ist alles teuer das
heißt sie müssen hochfahren es geht gar
nicht anders also wer uns sagt ja da
sind nur noch 20 prozent frei auf der
intensivstation der guckt sich nicht die
lage an das ist für die normale das
müssen wir machen und das ist auch nicht
irgendwie eine krankheit des
gesundheitssystems viele maschinen viel
personal viel techniker kostet geld um
dann müssen diese sind zusammengefasst
ist eigentlich es war schon immer
schlimmer auf der station ganz genau wo
ich nur als mathematisch mittel begabter
ausgestiegen bin war die tatsache dass
wir zu anfang der pandemie von herrn
sparen gehört haben wir haben 28.000
intensivbetten in deutschland zu einem
irgendwie anderen zeitpunkt mitten drin
mal hieß es dann ja menschen haben
22.000 intensivbetten und davon sind
unser hallo wo sind denn die anderen
also wenn mir jemand eine prozentuale
auslastung mitteilt aber sich die
bezugsgröße zwischendurch ändert dann
brauche ich wenigstens eine begründung
warum sich die bezugsgröße geändert hat
und das konnte in der regel die politik
nicht liefern das nimmt man einfach so
hin als nachrichten konsument aber es
ist einfach nicht logisch das habe ich
beschrieben 100 landkreise von 400 in
deutschland haben quasi ich sag mal
relativ trickreich ihre intensivbetten
abgemeldet die sie hatten das ist eine
definitionssache das haben aber nur 100
von 400 gemacht ist also ein kleiner
teil also möglicherweise haben die
anderen 300 es nicht verstanden dass man
das so machen hätte können und dafür
haben die dann ausgleichszahlung
bekommen also da sind wir wieder bei
ihrer eingangs these ich finde ich finde
eine sache hochinteressant
beziehungsweise wichtig auch was ralf
sagt es gibt so viele fragezeichen sie
schon bestehen
doch sagen wir brauchen endlich eine
aufarbeitung des testen also ein
untersuchungsausschuss möglicherweise
der hervorbringt was dort zu welchen
zeiten ehrlich gesagt er öffentlich war
welche daten es gab was politiker dazu
gesagt haben und ich glaube keine krise
hat die bevölkerung je so eingenommen so
eingeschnitten und darüber wird viel zu
wenig gesprochen können ja vielleicht
ist der spruch von jens spahn wir werden
uns für vieles entschuldigen müssen
wird daraus wir werden uns für videos
entschuldigen müssen wir noch mehr also
ich bin auch sehr gespannt doch wer
nicht lesen ich bin gespannt